what was what was that film with the
woman nicholas cage
and there's like numbers and there's a
kid who like has the knowing
that knowing i don't know how i remember
that's the one have you seen that movie
yeah i've seen that movie what is it i
can't remember but i remember being
really [ __ ] stupid
look at that nicholas cage like he like
stops like a plane crashing or something
no i i think because i i watched this as
a kid i remember he i think it's like
something to be a series or we just like
try and poorly recollect movies like
like what's this movie i want that
like this thing okay okay i'm going to
try and recreate this movie from what i
how do you remember this perfectly um
because okay so as a kid in the summer
uh this is going on another tangent now
so my summer's considered consisted of
me going to thailand and me spending
like six weeks in thailand and obviously
i wouldn't have something to do every
day so
so
like part of my childhood childhood
experience is going to the mall
and go and in like and just like in in
basically every southeast asian country
there be these stands where you have
these like dvd covers and you just like
you just like flip through the covers
and just choose which movies you'd want
to see and some of them weren't out on
dvd yet officially right so you just
flip through them and you just want i
want that one i want that one i want
that one and one that one and then
they'd ask you to uh go go walk in the
mall for like a good half an hour to an
hour and then they'll call you i'll tell
you when your purchase is ready right
which was a 100 totally legal of course
of course um but
southeast asia very strict copyright yes
yes yes yes um so like my summer would
just be basically watching every
blockbuster hollywood movie that came
out that year because that that i i look
forward to it because i could literally
pick every film through this day knowing
is still the best
and to this day i still remember knowing
that's why that's honestly why 50 first
dates almost went went on my three by
three because i had watched that so many
times what are you going to say because
of knowing
i was like what is this episode because
only one movie that tops no
yeah so like i've watched so many of
these films which are now what i
classify as like airplane films because
now i would not watch them in any other
circumstances unless i was on an
airplane um but
of knowing was one of the films that i
was stuck inside indoors in thailand
had nothing to do but just watch films
and uh from what i remember it was they
i think it had to do with like a time
capsule that was buried ages ago oh
right yeah that was it and there was
like a number like a cipher or something
yeah there was some kind of cipher
numbers or something that liked it and
that like predicted the apocalypse or
something
um
that sounds dumb and nicolas cage was
just like i see the future i see what's
going to happen the number is basically
and uh
stuff nicholas cage things happen yeah
and then uh the world literally ends
because i think it's a solar flare that
uh kills everyone uh spoilers if you
ever wanted to watch knowing i wanted to
watch if if he ever wanted to watch the
masterpiece that is nicholas cage's
knowing
um
how did we get on this topic
just talking about movies
is that a horror movie i think it is a
horror it's supposed to be a
horror as it is horrible i'm looking up
right now
i'm looking at right now knowing my name
is can we take a break because i need to
pee and i'm very hot right now